[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نحن نعمل في هذه المنطقه منذ عده عقود
واساس هذا النجاح هو اسلوب شراكاتنا مع
الصناعه لتحقيق رؤى الدول المتعدده مثال
على ذلك حاليا هو فضاء القتال ذي
الاتصالات متعدده النطاقات لان معاركنا
المستقبليه يجب ان تكون مرتبطه بشكل مباشر
بالمعلومات الانيه فمع توسعنا في المنطقه
نسعى لتنميه تجاربنا لكي نزود هذه القدرات
لاحتياجات المعارك المستقبليه
[موسيقى]
نحن فخورون جدا لتوقيع اتفاق مع شركه
السرب والعمل الذي يقومون به على
المنظومات الجويه غير الماهوله في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه انه في الحقيقه مزيج بين
الاستراتيجيه طويله الامد للشراكه من اجل
تطوير القدرات الجديده
[موسيقى]
فعبر هذه الشراكه سنعمل على تحقيق التكامل
مع منظومه
للاستشعار كما سنعمل على منظومه الطيار
الالي بيكولو ووصلت البيانات اللاسلكيه اس
سي اي اس ار لهذه المنصه فجوهر هذه الجهود
هو العمل مع شركاء والشركات في دول الشرق
الاوسط
[موسيقى]
بات عمر شركتنا الان ثلاثه اعوام منذ دمج
شركتي ريثيون ويو تي سي وقد وفر لنا هذا
الدمج امكانيه هائله لاستكشاف جميع
منتجاتنا لجمع قدرات الشركتين بشكل سلس
لكي نصل الى المعادله الشهيره واحد زائد
واحد يساوي اكثر من اثنين فاذا اخذنا بيئه
العمليات متعدده النطاقات فتشمل اجهزه
الاستشعار والتواصل وتفسير البيانات
والعمل ولدينا اجزاء من شركتنا تتعامل مع
كل واحده من هذه المراحل
[موسيقى]